all right hi everyone welcome to another
incremental language development design
review meeting uh we are looking at a
variety of topics here today
so first up tree scan traversal orders
12 general possibilities oh my gosh
okay
so
but i think there i think it's really
six times two
right not twelve
right it's factored as six
or three times two times two
right okay so let's let's
review
all right now obviously this is a trial
run for what we might do with things
like map in the future
right
right
yeah so
um so here we have tried to classify the
general possibilities and we wanted to
discuss with you possible naming schemes
and then there will be
other orders like for example for binary
trees so cases with more structure
but we believe these are all the general
the fundamental orders for generals
right let me remind myself
what i briefly understood
as i was working on i don't think it is
all i mean it depends what you mean by
by
you know
general case would be a general
permutation but we don't want to be that
general it's more like
the fundamental follow
vertical follow horizontal
no i understand that i understand that
so i mean this is you know look
this is a new layer of language design
because it is a um and it relates to a
lot of what i want to do with multi-way
computation
and um
you know parallelism and so on so let's
just remind ourselves what the issues
are here so let me just look at um
yeah
we have your nomenclature in the last
line oh i see
okay
so the left most outermost et cetera
okay
but let me remind myself how this worked
uh oh wrong post
um
there we go that's the right post
updating schemes the question of
evaluation order
okay
so
what we're thinking about here is we've
got these
tree positions right
yeah and the question is how do we sort
so i've had some there's some wfr
functions that do some of the sorting
right
yes
yes and i looked at them
okay so i mean the most general way to
do this is
with some kind of sorting function right
most general way to specify this is
you've given a you know
a set of candidates like this
right
you take every
the part number of every of every leaf
am i making sense yes so um so these
eight
are covered in the twelve possibilities
i don't care i don't care that's well in
general
the eight that you're talking about can
be determined by sorting positions but
there are four that can't be determined
by sorting positions okay i want to
understand that okay but the first thing
would be
what do you visit when
right right
okay so you've got a bunch of part
numbers
and
in general what you're doing is as you
said it's an arbitrary permutation there
is a sorting process where you don't
know what's on the leaves you just know
where the leaves are correct
yes indeed
okay and so then
what i'm saying is
that what you need is a sorting
criterion based on part numbers if i'm
not mistaken
that would be the fully general yes
that's what i'm saying so i'm saying we
could have a function that is called
basically that you know there's some
option which says traversal order arrow
and then it can be a sorting function
potentially
that is one way to do it that's the most
general way to do it
no it's not the most like there's four
traversal orders
not be covered by that okay explain
so it's
the ones i'm talking about are depth
order and reverse depth order
so there you need to actually know the
structure of the tree you can't just
look at the position
explain why
you need to
you know just from a position you can't
tell what the depth of the subtree is
why not it's just the length of the
position specification
no that's the level that the subtree is
on
oh you mean the depth below the subject
exactly
so i see some of these traversals um
okay okay okay i get it so that's
negative levels basically
yes exactly i was about to say it's
revenge of the negative levels
right so what this is
okay
so let's just review
what we know here okay
so
the first question is
there are levels
right and that is one classification of
so levels are basically the length of
the part specification
right yeah
positive levels the length of part
specification what you're saying is it's
also useful to know the negative level
specification
yes right
so this gives us so it's this
now what is the analog from the root of
the tree
we can go and we can find this is this
leaf here okay
this is this this node here
now you're also saying is there a way to
come up from the bottom of the tree and
find that node and you're saying the
only thing you're considering there
is what is the sub is what is the depth
of the subtree
but in principle you can consider all
kinds of attributes of the subtree
in principle you could have a sorting of
subtrees
am i making sense
i mean in principle
right the the
the top
what you're saying is the path from the
root to the node
is
what this is specifying right and so
you're sorting paths
and then you're also saying you could in
principle also sort with respect to the
subtree
the hanging subtree is that correct
yep
okay now in principle you could sort
according to all kinds of other things
as well and maybe that's what you were
starting to say with balanced trees
what is that what is the additional
sorting you can do with balanced trees
well so for binary trees there's
something called an in-order traversal
so you do the left subtree then the
parent and then the right subtree
okay which is different from the
numerical order of a of a a tree that's
been labeled by its numbers or not or
it's the same
do you understand what i'm asking
every node in a binary tree right every
node you get a first numbering like one
to n
and you in order i think that might be
no but but in a binary tree right the
binary tree represents
you know if if we go
i don't know whether we can say k
retreat
um
you know 15 or something okay so here
if i say
i don't know if this is correct for that
i don't think it is it's probably minus
one there
okay so zero
one
that's not right zero that's zero one
that's one one i'm not sure if this is
right but but basically this is adding
this is this part numbering right
and you could imagine something where
you're going and maybe this isn't what
you're doing well where you're going in
the order of
the binary decomposition of the parts
am i making sense
did you understand what i'm saying
i got a little lost i'm sorry okay well
here but let's just take this tree
just do it in the order in which these
nodes are labeled
isn't that just our what we call the
level or traversal or i forget well it
may be but it's not one of these
traversals yes it is it's outermost
leftmost
really
yeah so post order pre-order level order
and reverse level order
are referring to these eight that you
have in the table okay
wait wait wait wait so what is the
additional ordering for a binary tree
that is not covered by this
the additional ordering would be the one
that goes like eight nine
or eight four nine and then two
and then ten five four nine wait a
minute eight four
nine yep and then two
and then ten
five
eleven
and then what is that is that something
which comes from some kind of recursion
is that natural for some kind of that's
natural for some kind of depth so
there's three kinds of depth first
traversals
there's pre post and in order
okay
and and this is useful for like um
binary search trees
okay all right okay
let me let me tell you my major problem
with all of this stuff okay
we haven't started doing
serious meetings about this multi-way
computation story
and it is certainly related to this
let me give you an example i was working
on just yesterday
okay
the the issue is
um
let's see how the best show this to you
uh well here i might be able to just
show you
um
okay
this is a friendly multi-way graph
and well this is an example here okay
see this nest graph here
yep
so that's generated by that
thing there okay so now
if you think about these pieces here if
you think about every step here as a
computation
we can ask in what order can this
computation be done okay so here this is
and this is a
jose friendly thing this is a story of
foliations
this particular one doesn't have any
interesting foliations it has no sense
of space
because it has that n goes to n plus one
so it's a partial order which defines
the thing to always go
in this
in it it it doesn't allow anything to be
space like separated
does everybody hear physics
aware do i should i explain what what
i'm talking about here or do i not need
to i'm not physics aware okay all right
okay so the basic point is
in
space-time right
there are
if
you say two events are time-like
separated if you just you have an event
you just sit in the same place time
passes and you have another event
does that make sense
yeah that's time like separation space
like separation is
events are at different places in space
and
they are
no light signal can go from one event to
the other
right so a light signal you get a light
cone where you start off at some at some
position in space time you produce this
light cone
okay that is this expanding region that
can be affected you have a flash of
light and it expands and if you plot it
in space time it'll be a cone does that
make sense so far that's like the out
component in this graph exactly exactly
so right that's that's the light cone
okay so space like separated points
are ones that
cannot
be in each other's futures like future
light cones
okay they're points where and the point
is that in a post set from a post set
point of view
the
possible so you can you can make a
choice
of what counts as two
what what
which points you say are simultaneous
okay
if that makes sense right because you
can't say they're simultaneous if
they're time like separated they have a
definite time ordering
makes sense
yep
but if they're space-like separated they
don't have a definite time ordering
they could be in any time order in
principle you could say
the mars lander landed
two years ago
and um
uh you know that's just a choice of
coordinate system you could say it's now
you know the year 2001 on mars
and it's a slightly funky coordinate
system but you could it's not
actually that's a bad example that's a
bad example because by that time never
mind don't forget is this like the
different levels in the tree on the left
yes
exactly yes right so so in this tree
there are so if this is an event
these are in the future light cone of
that event
this is not
so these two can be space like separated
and the notion our space like separated
and the idea is that you make a
foliation you make a series of slices
here and those you call
the things that are happening at
successive moments in time so it's a
generalization of what you're doing here
with tree ordering because you can say
there are multiple things which are
space like separated which are all
happening at the same time
does that make sense so what you're
doing here is you're turning this tree
into a total order
you know you're generating a total order
on the tree that says visit this then
this then this then this
the generalization of that which is the
essence of the existence of space
i think
is
that there can be events
you know nodes here that
can be done simultaneously
does that make sense
um
i see the general connection i'm kind of
confused because like some traversal
orders can go the opposite direction of
the arrows
i
i understand those are not valid
foliations of space time i mean you can
choose to do it that way right you can
you can
this
you're saying you can define a total
order
on here
that completely violates the arrows
okay
i would say it's just reversing the
arrow of time
yes that's fine you could say that but i
mean the reason that we're thinking
about this the reason that we care about
the arrows here is we're imagining this
is a computation that progresses with
time
right we're imagining that what happens
later isn't known what uh what when when
you're making the earlier stuff that's
not the situation you have with trees
with trees it's a data structure it's
all there
do you see what i'm saying
whereas what we're interested in here is
the thing is growing over time
but it's growing down here
yeah in your case physics determines a
direction in our case there are some
problems in which you need to know first
what happens to the parents and other
problems in which you need to know first
what happens to the children
right so so you're not
so i mean to give a sense of that
um
um
let's see i was just looking for
something
um
how do i have this here we go
okay
so here we have
a post set basically a representation of
a post set
right
this is a depth first traversal
that
yes that that satisfies the postset
relation
making sense
that's a breadth first traversal that
satisfies the postset relation
that is it shouldn't be the case that
anything which
occurs uh
later in the earlier in the post set
has to have also occurred earlier in the
total ordering
that make sense
okay so so this would be this is
a dag
as opposed to just a tree here
and
what we're saying is
right so you're trying to generate a
total order here what i'm saying is
there is a generalization of that in
which you imagine you're doing parallel
processing right where you're traversing
the tree but there's some parallelism
involved does that make sense
and in other words the tree traversal
orders you are defining are great
you know so long as you're operating on
a sequential processor
yes right and i i
can see how some of these traversals
could be done in parallel immediately
right but the point is that the
this question of um
this foliation business so to give you a
sense of that
okay so there's a trivial foliation here
right does that make sense so each slice
the events in that slice of space like
separated okay this is another foliation
there's still space like separated here
okay and but this is a different
ordering this is a different way of
making the
the sort of um i don't know what kind of
ordering it is it's a it's a
you know
it's an ordering but some things can be
done in parallel
make sense
yeah
okay so the reason that i'm concerned
about this is because
okay so to just to be clear
the thing that has been a confusion for
me for 40 years
is
the relationship between an expression
tree and an evaluation graph
okay so as you run the evaluator two
things are happening you're recursing
through the expression tree
and you're also
re-evaluating and recursing through the
reevaluation process
does that make sense
so i mean in an example like this
okay this n goes to n plus 1 to n
that's in a sense evaluation recursion
as opposed to
recursing i mean in other words if we
did this as a substitution of some more
complicated thing we might recurse into
that more complicated structure
then do this then we we have the
recursion inside the structure as well
as the recursion associated with
reevaluation
do you mean that you allow yourself to
revisit some notes
no i just mean that there is a okay
imagine you're looking at the execution
trace of the evaluator
okay
there are two things that go on in that
execution trace one is
map like traversal of expressions
right where the traversal order we're
using we have two traversal orders one
for functions that don't hold their
arguments and the other functions that
do hold their arguments
in the case where they don't hold their
arguments it's depth first traversal
right right i think it's what left most
in the most or something is that right
yeah
i would just qualify that i think both
technically are considered depth first
okay
but which one is that which one is the
the leftmost innermost is the not
holding version okay what's called
that's called a post order depth first
and the holding one i think is left most
outermost which is preorder depth first
okay
okay
okay all right
so
uh
all right
so that's recursion in the expression
the other kind of recursion is
you got a result
now you reevaluate that result
see what i'm saying
f 7 evaluated to g of 19.
now you evaluate g of 19.
that's essentially a time recursion
one was an expression space recursion
and the other is a time recursion
is something
since yeah you can see that
okay so
that's a very confusing thing and as we
generalize
to
the case okay so this is a typical
multi-way graph right it's got multiple
threads of evaluation going on here
and
in this particular case there's not a
lot that can be done in parallel in a
very interesting way because of the
details of that but even if we do this
case here
where we're taking oh this is rather
messy but but we're basically taking
pairs of numbers
and we're updating those pairs of
numbers there are things that can now be
done non-trivially in parallel
that make sense just like here we can
obviously do lots of stuff in parallel
does this make sense
yep yep
okay so
like in a depth first traversal you
could conceivably be doing each child in
parallel
or a level order you could be doing each
level in parallel
i think so yes yes yes i think that's
right i think here
you could be doing
right in in a tree
there's a lot more you can do in
parallel than in a general dag
that makes sense
because you can always do in a tree you
can always do
sort of independent branches in parallel
right
right so
if we're talking about like the
expression space traversals
but um
the thing about reevaluation that might
be
exactly that gets more complicated right
as soon as you have shared
sub-expressions it's much more
complicated
right
okay let's talk some practicality here
about what we want because
let me let me just explain
there are two failures two carcasses as
far as i'm concerned in all of this
one is what happened in smp where i had
a parametrization for evaluation
ordering which nobody ever understood
and two
is our breadth first scan function which
again nobody understands
right it's totally messy and i mean
let's take a look at the breadth first
scan function
okay so what is this doing exactly
and how does this
do you understand what this is i mean
isn't this related to
um
i mean so this works on general graphs
and i don't
totally understand that case but the
point is it gives access to all kinds of
different events based on whether you're
just discovering it
a vertex or an edge or when you
there's a distinguishment between
discovering and visiting
right
but it has a frontier and the question
is
how does it pick its frontier because
what you're describing with your
traversal order is a frontier picking
scheme
isn't it
i mean for me
okay
foliations are the frontier that is
every as you move through the the system
you know the foliations define the
frontier that you reach now
again physics idea
you know in the absence of closed time
like curves
that's the dag condition for these
things right the closed time-like curve
is something where even though you
thought you were progressing forwards in
time even though
your edges were going you know down down
down like this is an example of a
trivial closed timeline curve because
you think you're going to the future
down here but actually you return to the
to say in this case the same place but
you could imagine there was a an arc
from here back to there that would
represent a closed time-like curve
does that make sense
yep
i know jose understands this but but um
uh and it's i understands it too
i don't believe in close time like
curves because you know my my whole
dissertation was on
you know making things globally
hyperbolic
right well i also i'm not an enthusiast
close timeline curve right there
yes but um
i also deny the existence of close time
like curves in the real universe i don't
know whether jose has worked on on
metrics and things that have close time
like curves but
um
okay so we're all we're all anti-closed
time-like curves i've only worked on uh
trying to help science fiction movies
that have close time-like curves and
trying to unscramble them
the
um
the uh
um
okay
so
what's my point here so my point is
this function not a very successful
function in my opinion i mean i think
this function is is hard to understand
for most people
and i don't you know how does it pick
its frontier
anybody got any idea
okay so it's got an order here so it's
visiting but boy somebody should turn
change that into an echo um
so
this is visiting one two three okay i
don't quite understand why that do you
understand why it's doing that and how
does that is that a pre-order traversal
or something that's a level order right
right
okay so why is that
go ahead yeah so the relation with
what what we have for trees on the left
is that we don't give access to
discovery
just visiting
and we
ignore edges so the only action is when
you visit a node you apply a function to
it
okay
okay so let's try to understand what
uh
okay
all right so let's talk about your
traversal order in the context of map
okay in addition to so
okay my biggest concern is i really want
to put in this multi-way stuff in which
you are basically defining
i mean the concept that the proto
concept
is to have this construct called multi
which represents
a
a set
of elements here
but i think multi
requires foliations
in other words to define you have
with a particular traversal order to
particular evaluation order you will get
a sequence of multis generated they
represent
the objects that exist in particular
foliations
that make sense jose do you understand
what i'm talking about
i think my interpretation of what you
are saying is that
what ian is presenting here is traversal
orders for
tree map or triscan
which will not
change the structure of the tree however
if we wanted to have some sort of
traversal order for tree replace part
which allows re changing the structure
of the tree as the function is working
then we would have to worry about time
in the sense of
in the sense of re-evaluation in the
sense of the reevaluation process
exactly revaluation as changing the tree
as you
traverse the tree right so i'm saying
that even if
i switch the same but but
my point here
yes i am i am more concerned with these
dynamically being produced but i'm
imagining that there's this concept of a
multi
which is
essentially the content of a folio of a
slice and a foliation
right like you know imagine that we have
a thing called multi
which is like which is auto listable
if you understand what i'm saying
now
the big problem with multi
is that
unlike when you have chains of functions
f of g of h of x
where the causal graph of the evaluation
is trivial it's just a chain
that's not true for the multi-case
but isn't multi-increased just the fact
that there are multiple children
i mean
yes
yes yes it's much more straightforward
with trees right but the reason i'm
bringing all this up is because i don't
want to design for trees that's
incompatible with what we want to do
later
i see
okay that's that's my real reason for
making big fuss about this right now
okay plus i'm also interested in the
whole
multi um thing i mean i'll show you just
an example
of
um
okay so this is
the notion the basic notion here
is
potentially
of a computation object
okay so so what's roughly happening is
if we take this whole multi-way graph
there is a sense in which you know okay
so in an ordinary computation we tried
with trace
to have some way of recording
the computation process
okay it didn't work very well
this is yet more complicated as things
get to be done in parallel
um
not sure what this is exactly
what is that that's oh that's nice
that's very nice application of nest
tree
that's really cool
so
but nest tree oh my gosh what does an s3
do mass tree
it doesn't have any evaluation order
issue is that a true statement
or does it
it must do because it's nesting
okay
so nest tree has two
it's really two functions one is growing
from a seed and the other is its action
on a tree which grows each leaf
right but it must have a traversal order
issue because it must be deciding
whether it
maybe the order
of the leaves but not in order for the
whole tree
okay fair enough
right so the whole point of a
computation object
ah boy it's complicated here okay let's
let's look back at what you've got but
you understand why i'm what i'm trying
to connect this to yes no maybe
i think i see the generalization
and
i i was planning that this will be one
of these cases in which we have a
functional notation for the fully
general case and then some named cases
which are much simpler
i agree
i just don't want to mess up
the you know
we are not proposing anything here for
the general notation just unnamed cases
and actually we could use even multiple
naming schemes that are all understood
in input
right
okay so let's say we had a traversal
order and we also applied that to map
right
so these examples here the numbers are
showing the order in which the nodes are
visited it's always the same tree but
the numbers you see they are different
okay so you're proposing traversal
direction and traversal order
correct
not really the truth is that
the last thing ian and i discussed is
just having a single traversal order
with named strings
yeah for all the possibilities but
the implementation that ian currently
has has this this separation in in
traversal order and traversal direction
so it's six times two
yeah it happens that each of these
traversals has a left and right variant
but we're concerned about
potential like in the general case you
might not always have a left and right
variant
so what the general case will do you
know might have
what is it called booster phone what is
that thing called you know you know
language is where you go instead of left
to right right to left they go left to
right and then they go back the other
way right to left then they snake like
that right so that's an argument against
having the traversal direction option
yes
um
okay by the way michael on the
livestream is asking is this equivalent
to happens before relation in
distributed systems yes it is
the post that relation yes it is
um
and like so many things in the world
these questions have come up in many
different places
all right so
what is the relationship between
okay breadth first search on a graph
i mean
so
does the depth first scan function that
we have for a graph
also work on a tree
no
so like for example here breadth first
scan this could be a tree data structure
here
don't say any reason that shouldn't be
supported
it could start by converting the tree
into a graph
yeah
fine whatever it wants to do
but there's got to be consistency in
okay all vertices adjacent to the
currently visited vertex are visited
first
i see so this is basically going out
in a
sort of a
this is basically making it to huygens
principle
story it's kind of making light cones
from every point
does that make sense
yep
and sometimes it revisits itself
so by the way there should be an example
in the documentation
where you take a general graph maybe
this is the example here
uh
my gosh
what a complicated mess
what we should show here
is the thing growing outwards
i see the problem is this is a scan
and what you've got is a
tree map
which for some bizarre reason we don't
have a breadth-first map
for a graph why don't we
see what i'm
asking don't have any kind of map for a
graph
right and the reason we don't
is because
right now
for a tree there's a distinction between
structure and payload
then that distinction is much messier
for a graph
but in principle
we could have a breadth-first map for a
graph that
would affect the payload
well but what happens if two
nodes produce the same output via the
function
then the new graph will be
very different
well
no but i mean what you're saying is
it's like
i see so the point that you're making is
with map
every
every node in the expression tree is
visited only once by map
but with a breadth first scan in a graph
a node could in principle be visited
many times
in the scan
well
not really the point i was making is
that a map function would take a graph
and return another graph with new nodes
but perhaps two different nodes of the
original graph
were mapped
to the same node
which means that the structure of the
new graph would be very different
no but you're assuming which i wasn't
that
the the graph map
actually changes the graph
i'm saying one of the things it could do
is change only payloads
just like tree map changes only payloads
it's only tree replace part that will
change the structure of the tree
well
changing the
i'm sort of like the payload in a graph
is just the vertex name changing that
will change the graph in general
we'll change the tree or the graph
the graph the graph
you have a graph no no i agree i agree
yes okay okay i get what you're saying
okay what i was imagining is with an
annotation you could perfectly well have
a graph map that affects annotations but
does not affect vertex names
yes okay
the reason is that in a tree
your vertex names are irrelevant to the
structure because they are payload
they're not structure
right
right
yeah
but the issue
okay so let me just understand
the issue that i've been obsessing about
in the case of
multi-way computation
is the issue um
let's see
uh
you know that reminds me i need to
um
is the issue that the composition of
functions is no longer straightforward
in other words if you've got
a
thing where you got to this level right
with jagged line across here right
you got to that you made a multi to that
level
sort of knowing how to compose that is
non-trivial
if that makes sense
you have to have causal information to
know how to go on i think
unlike a function
a single chain or you just need to know
whatever the output was and you keep
bashing it so to speak
that make sense
i think another important difference is
that in your case you create the graph
as you go
well we always assume we have an
original tree to which we apply things
and and even we don't change it in a
story exactly but the point that i'm
making is traversal orders
are
are things both for expression traversal
and for reevaluation
they're relevant for both of those cases
it's the same idea but it's being
applied in two different ways
right just like in the breadth first
scan case
its notion of the traversal order
is this huygens principle thing
um
okay
so
let's just understand this so
you're saying
for a tree
which is the same story as of map
whatever you do for traversal order for
a tree you could as well do for
traversal order for map true statement
well assuming the new expression with
map is not going to change structurally
if the function evaluates and changes
then we have changed the tree
no no that's not right that's not how
map works right i mean map
map just paints things on the expression
tree if the expression tree then goes
into connections as it evaluates that's
its business
i see what's doing yeah
they
so the only difference is
i mean if i do look i mean if if i write
something where i'm just saying
um
let's do the explicit thing so let's
take
um we can take one of these we can take
this thing here
why does that beep why can't i
copy it
why is that beeping
what the hell is it doing
now it copied why did it not copy before
what
what
what
bug bug bug bug
um maybe something related to the fact
that it's inside the grid i i
no idea
could somebody send me a tree
probably if you you see that it's a cell
that it's uh closed if you open it there
should be there yeah okay all right
there's a tree uh we should figure out
that bug with the grid
i i got it
okay
all right so there's a tree
so now
let's say tree expression
okay
somewhat funky but anyway let's let's
say
uh
how do i make the tree expression with
lists there
without without head head wrapping
can someone i'm asking
no
i want this as a bunch of nested lists
not as a
not as a not using this node as the head
wrapper for this
i think you would have to do like re
replace repeat it
head arguments goes to list
that sounds horrifying i should be able
to have a way to turn this into
well it's not totally obvious what this
should be
because of that one okay i admit it's
not totally obvious what it should be do
so take that expression do expression
tree
comma adams
so you're saying you want basically this
tree expression but everywhere there's
the interior nodes you want to list
i think so if i'm not too confused
think so yes i think so what happens if
you no that's not right that's not right
i i don't know what i want i'm confused
but let me take this thing here okay and
let me just say
um map
of
echo
onto this
at level infinity
and let me say heads goes to true
but
sorry in the previous expression what
happens if you do three expressions of
that tree that you generated
oh it's null right so i think what you
want is this list instead of now
why is it null and not list by the way
because that's what we put in the
uh in the empty as what we consider as
empty payloads
274
using
lists um
maybe list of
uh slot 2.
i mean we're going down a slippery slope
here
oh yeah i i do think in this case here
of this tree expression thing i don't
know what else tree expression has in it
i think there's an argument that this
argument should have something where you
can generate
or you can tell it what to put in
instead of those nulls perhaps
see what i'm saying
i'm not sure we're getting off topic
here but what i'm trying to show
is
that
map has a traversal order
right richard on our live stream points
yeah so map does a post order
traversal
yeah it's not the same structure i agree
three should be a child of two but the
thing we're getting here isn't the same
structure
this this original tree
as richard has pointed out here is much
more like this
even that's not really right
i mean i agree that that sub piece looks
right
okay it's somewhat confusing to see how
to do this i i think the question is if
this was lisp what would this tree be
i can answer the other direction which
is if this was list that expression
the tree would become the atoms tree
so your n of 274 converts an expression
to a
s expression basically
okay
okay all right but but let's look at
this traversal here
so
i believe it is the case that your
traversal order for trees
for tree map is identical to what we
would need for a traversal order for map
that is my claim
any disagreement with that
no i i think the traversal orders
suggested by ian are
applicable to map too okay so let's
understand what it would look like
in map
what is negative levels
what is the if i do the same thing
and i do level
i don't even know what the heck i'm
doing here
um i mean does map
okay so if i say level minus one there
okay that does the same traversal order
that's just saying which part of the
tree to paint
try least minus one i think that that
meant from minus one is equivalent to
infinity
right so that's only going to be the
leaves
okay so my point is for map right now
the the level spec is not a traversal
order the level spec is just saying
which
part of the tree do you paint
right map always does a post order
traversal
um post order means you're at the bottom
of the tree first and then you come up
um yeah
the bottom of the first child
recursively right we can see that
happening here dialed
okay not like the entire bottom of the
tree like you're going in
tile by child all the way to the bottom
what
you're going in here
you don't hit all of the leaves first or
the
exactly you're doing a depth first
traversal right tree
which you call in your nomenclature what
post order
people are going to understand depth
first a lot more than they can
understand post order
well so post order and
pre-order and in order for binary trees
are all depth first and those are
standard names for different kinds of
depth first traversals
okay well we should have a default depth
first that does presumably post order
yeah that's the default if you don't
specify
right now
entry scan
well so that's what you're saying i
understand but there's depth order depth
first or is that something completely
different something completely different
okay that's not good
okay so depth first which is a brand
name so to speak for an ordering we got
to support that
and presumably it means what you're
calling post order
yeah now arguably it's better to have a
more descriptive name like depth first
you know
depth first pre-order depth first post
order
you see what i'm saying
right
yeah
i mean the alternative would be
just like you have right
could you have a post along with the
right so it's depth first post right or
something
i mean the default is depth first post
left isn't it
yeah
so
in the uh agenda we had a proposal for
generalizing pre and post to the other
traversals even though that's not
um
standard
but it is standard for depth first
okay but so so here but what we're
saying is what i'm suggesting let's see
like under level order i have pre-level
order left
as a another option
so here using pre to mean start at the
root and post meaning end at the root
i understand so so other names for this
will be depth first
and then there's top down bottom up
right
right
yeah i was also
looking for something that looks as
geometric as left right
okay well top down bottom up seems like
that's that isn't it
yeah yeah because i i cannot remember
preamp post nor can i
right
so okay so we've got so then we've got
is left and right
but we also should support okay what is
outermost versus innermost and so on
it depends on whether you do
outermost before or after the leftmost
like there's a difference between left
most out or most i know
yeah i know
so how do we deal with that so we we
have a list so what outermost refers to
is
uh
the lowest level first and innermost
means the
uh
greatest level first
so how do those relate to bottom up
versus top and top down
so outermost would be
like from the top
okay so it's top down
from the bottom up
okay so this is so top down
is otherwise known as
uh
outermost right
i mean i kind of think we should support
multiple names here bottom up is
innermost
i should have used that in that in that
combinator post actually i mean these
are standard names outermost leftmost
outermost and so on well outer and inner
make more sense if you're looking at an
expression because then you're talking
about brackets
whereas top and bottom make more sense
when you're looking at the tree i see
okay fair enough
okay
i mean we could call this
um
do we have a place where i can save this
is this agenda saved somewhere did you
send it by email
i just sent it to you by email
okay i have to save this somewhere let
me actually save this in my
um
i guess i'm going to save this
in a place that will not be readily
accessible which is unfortunate
so i don't really know what to do with
this thought that's going in my
multi-way computation folder which i
suppose i should move into the language
design area
okay
yep i got
it you
you probably have access to that i'm not
sure if you do
um
okay
so
okay so let's just copy over what we're
doing here
so then what we're saying here
is
um
you know this would be
an alternative name here will be outer
first inner first
and then if we say left first
right first or left
i mean actually this is left right right
left isn't it
yep
so
then the question is is it so left right
outer
well i mean the the natural thing here
would be
okay this is top down so it's where you
start and what direction you're going in
so this would be
i mean the analog there would be
outer in
in or out
which is a little weird
i have to say
that our tree expression expression tree
expression graph you know graph tree
graph all those kinds of things i really
like those i'm
i'm finally having no trouble
remembering them
so i just you know this idea of the
the sort of the the paired thing
of
where you're you know what
where you started where you're going
doesn't seem bad to me
but it is a little bit strange
that
the order here
so how does that relate in sort
we've got the possibility of multiple
sorting functions
and
is the way that you give multiple
sorting functions and the way they d tie
themselves is that related to this or is
that completely different from this
i don't think i understand well so i i
think that the eight on the left
are about sorting the four on the right
are not really and even the ones that
are about sorting they're not
implemented by
sorting
i understand that but i'm asking a
question
so for instance
if we wanted to get okay okay okay so
the next question is relation to sort
orders
there's two two points relation to sort
orders and there's the relation to the
operation of sort
okay
so we have sort and reverse sort for
example that's the sort of thing you're
asking right yes that's right and but
i'm asking
okay when we do lexicographic sword
okay
versus sort
that affects if if i take my examples
wherever they were
um
these examples here
okay so i have this thing here
right
that has a sort order
okay now i do like a graphic sort of
that
and i get a different order
right see what i'm saying yep
so
this
traversal order thing is also if i'm not
mistaken and ordering on part numbers
right and the question is how do you
access
the named ordering
which applies to part numbers
in the case of
you know tree mapping
you get what i'm saying
yeah so this is the permutation we were
talking about at the beginning and ian
pointed out that it's not enough to know
the parts you also need access to the
whole tree to know where that part put
it another way it's you can't get it by
pairwise sorting the elements you really
need to look at all of the elements
for some of the traversals okay i get it
but which ones but there are some
that you don't need to do that for and
what we definitely want
is if there is a sort order here right
that sort order should be accessible to
sort
that's what i'm saying
i'm not saying that sort alone is
sufficient to do this tree stuff
okay
that's an interesting suggestion by
sander if sought by that's an
interesting suggestion
let's say that sort by had access to a
hash position
hash depth
a bunch of other things like that
right
no depth
that's not quite right this isn't quite
right but but this is another
so what you're saying is
if we were doing the permutation thing
here
one thing to do would be to have access
to
that information about
the sub trees if we had access to the
information about subtrees we could
decide sort order i mean sorry traversal
order by sorting
correct
i think so but it needs access to the
whole structure
okay
okay
so it's a comment here
um from richard
attribute grammars make use of top-down
and bottom-up traversals
and even give them their own names
inherit versus synthesize okay i didn't
know that
it doesn't surprise me that this would
come up in attribute grammars
um
okay let's let's zoom out for a second
here to what we're looking at okay
so
i i'm basically buying your claim that
we should have a bunch of name traversal
orders okay i'm saying that they should
work for map as well
i'm wondering
whether there is a concept of those
traversal orders for sort
what do i mean by that i mean sort
itself
and i'm just fuzzily thinking about this
doesn't it as it looks to structures
doesn't it have to decide which part of
the structure is the more important one
to consider for sorting purposes and
doesn't it have to do that by
essentially a traversal order
i think the key point in sort is the
ordering function which is a much
simpler operation it's going to take
just two elements and it's going to
decide well i realized that but but jose
what i'm saying is this
imagine that we have here
okay
a
you know i don't know how this lecture
okay the lexicographic sort
is a uh
innermost leftmost sort is that correct
in the sense that what it does is it is
examining these
expressions
in an innermost leftmost way to decide
what it cares about
see what i'm saying as opposed to
an outermost way where it's going to
care about the length of the whole top
expression
or something
just making any sense
otherwise i claim there's an analogy
not at the level i agree the ordering
function it's just a slam dunk it just
does its ordering right
but what i'm saying is by the time you
are
calling out ordering
by words so to speak
i claim there is an analogy between the
depth first you know all that kind of
stuff here
i see so you're saying that we could
have different orders just by deciding
that we have a different traversal
that's correct that we care about things
in a different order in the data that
we're looking at and i claim that we can
take we should be able to export
directly certain aspects maybe the whole
thing of the traversal order here to
determine sorts and that that will in
fact give you the thing that i had in
that table here it will give you for the
part numbers so i'm gonna i'm making the
claim
which i may not be quite accurate that
okay these are part numbers and so what
was top down in the expression tree
becomes something about left most right
right left right for this or something
it becomes the length of the position of
the part
so i think what the stephen is saying is
that in lexicographic sort for example
we compare two of these lists from left
to right
what if we wanted to do from right to
left or what if it's deeper and we want
to define the
the order of comparisons yeah exactly
right which comparisons do you do so
you've got two expressions
and you are doing comparisons
and there's a question of which things
do you compare first so for example here
what we're seeing is we're going depth
first in lexicographic sort we're doing
depth first and we're just comparing
in some sense the you know we're just
drilling in and comparing the first
thing
whereas here we're looking at the whole
thing
in the big
and seeing what the list lengths are
right
yeah we could easily create as an
ordering function which is based on
trace scan with two trees
and then that trace scan would define
the order
so so we take the two expressions
convert them to trees
then
trouble i think it's something like that
yes
and then as soon as one of the
compilations is true or false
we
have this decided
sandra is saying you want to sort on
depth first but then lex graphic sort on
position
i'm pretty sure we can parametrize like
a graphic sort in terms of traversal
order
i think lexicographic sort is a version
of sort with the traversal order
that's what i think
that makes sense
yes and and only looking at depth
at the first level
but that's presumably a
a top-down
story
or something
that that's presumably simulatable by a
traversal order
i see i see if the heads are the same
you just keep going in until yes right
right i see yeah
nick is commenting there should be a
general traverse function that takes an
expression returns a list of cell
expressions
not a bad idea i mean although
i think that's just level with a
traversal order
yes that's right that's level exactly
that's level
which is perhaps misnamed
now
no i see it's it's simply level with a
traversal order it is level
to infinity for example
but it is a traversal order which
determines the sorting of the things
yeah
right i mean we could imagine a traverse
function we should think about that
uh just as an alternative which is which
is a a um
uh which is the equivalent of level
within in you know level x per infinity
right
okay let's let's go back up here and
look at these so one thing that's still
bothering me
is the fact that when we have a list of
of of traversal order specifications
that it matters what order the traversal
order specifications are in
do you get what i'm saying
that's a possible notation perhaps we
can have just 12 different strings
and they each one
possibly i mean the thing is
and have some of them are equivalent
like different names for the same thing
yeah i i would prefer to have it in a
list but i just i just think people are
going to be confused by the fact that it
matters whether it says left right
inner outer
right so like
where i have the list post order right
that
doesn't matter like if you instead had
that as right and post order it's still
the same thing it's only when you're
thinking of the right most leftmost and
innermost outermost specifically that
this comes up
but so if we said outer in our outer
which are synonyms for top down and
bottom up
right outer inner is the synonym for top
down correct
inner outer is the synonym for bottom up
left right it's very clear what that is
right left it's clear what that is
right and i think it's much clearer than
just saying left
so i think one
so sorry we have three times two times
two so your names control the two times
two
so then we need names for the other
three
what are the other three
depth first
level order and depth order
okay the names that people are going to
know
are
depth first
breadth first
does that mean something
yeah breadth first is the same as level
order
okay so that's level order
depth first refers to both post order
and pre-order
okay but but
and and so i'll say depth first post
order pre-order breadth first and level
order are all standard everything else
here is not standard
we can have the standard names as well
like left most and so on it's fine
but we need names that people can
actually understand
right okay so depth so what you're
saying is the three cases are depth
first pre-order depth first post-order
and then breadth first is that right
pre-order and post-order is one case
those are both depth first
i know i know i know i know so what
you're saying is well so you didn't list
a third case the third case is depth
order
which isn't like it's just my name that
i made up because i couldn't find it oh
yeah hold on hold on so you're saying
this depth first pre
and the step first post is that correct
what does that what do those mean
yeah usually you say pre-order depth
first or post-order depth first okay
what does that mean what does it mean
visit the parent before the children
post means you visit the parent after
the children
and then those what we were planning to
call top down button up exactly
okay so we shouldn't do that i mean we
can also have
okay so that's those are the standard
names like if we're supporting multiple
names
okay okay wait hold on what is outermost
what is outermost is is that a pre-order
thing post-order thing is that something
completely different
because outermost is what i understood
outer inner to be
right outer inner means is the same as
outermost correct
yes
outer
outer corresponds to pre
enter all right so there's a yet another
name here so this is pre-order here
yeah so that use of pre is specific to
depth first but yes those correspond in
the case of depth first
nobody uses pre for breadth first
traversals
but they could it could
okay so that's pre-order
this and this could be post order here
so that's the correspondence okay so
those are all equivalent then outer
inner inner outer top down bottom up etc
okay
okay
so
okay so here
is this right we've got depth first
so wait a minute depth first
with inner outer means what
depth first with outer means you visit
the root no no no i'm not talking outer
i'm talking our names outer and uh so
outer inner and depth first would be
first you do the root and then you drill
down
depth first with inner out wait wait
wait wait first you do the root here
and then you go one two four eight yes
nine blah blah blah blah blah okay
depth first
with outer would be you start at eight
why the heck is it called depth first if
you're gonna start at the root if you
look at the call tree of both of these
it's exactly the same traversal it's
just what order do you apply the
function do you apply the function
before you do the traversal or do you
apply the function after you do the
traversal the traversal is exactly the
same
i see okay and there's certainly
standard names depth first and breadth
first are standard names and i don't see
a reason to change that
okay
okay fine so do we now have it i mean if
we've got depth first breadth first
comma
what's that
there's a third thing on that first line
that we need which is what depth order
what does that mean that's the negative
levels
okay that will be depth last
presumably
i mean it's probably best to try to come
up with a name that doesn't have depth
in it but why
because it's confusing with depth first
no no no no but what it is is it's going
it's
it's doing the the bottom of the entire
tree rather than
going child by child which is what depth
first means
i see if you did depth order you'd get
all of 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15. so it's
basically leaves first
i like that
and and
yeah
and so its outer inner
would be
really leaves last
and its inner outer would be leaves
first
but the problem is with depth first
you go down two ailees
i know that but it's depth but you're
not even going down if you're doing the
outer inner
you're doing the evaluation without
having gone down
i i think the key point here is that
depth first and leaves first are give
the priority to the vertical and breadth
first to the horizontal
but but the depth first is counting
depths from the root and leaves first is
counting
heights from the bottom i
disagree i think depth first is vertical
and then both breadth first and leaves
first are horizontal
really well i i realize leaves first is
kind of a mixture because it depends on
the on the on the skyline of the bottom
you can see andrew is commenting we
already have a name decision
from breadth first scan and depth first
scan
yes but the difficult decision is the
third one this leaves first i know i
know i know i know but even depth first
is actually somewhat confusing i mean we
actually know what it means
right
but it isn't in fact depth the deepest
first i mean you know other names here
could include
um
deepest first but that isn't even right
that's not correct because the outer
inner version of that
uh
right outer inner and inner outer will
mess with you if you're using this first
thing because it's going to swap first
and last
well i mean we're going to use depth
first because we've already determined
that's that's a notion of of um
um
of ordering
i'm going to have to go in a second here
um
george in a livestream is commenting in
and post order traversal yes we yes we
know
um
and we will certainly support those
names
um
but that's
you know that's that will be equivalent
pre-order is equivalent to outer inner
okay so
what's wrong with leaves first
i i i like it
nothing
nothing really i'm just pointing out
that if you did
[Music]
outer outer end
but leaves first
last but it's the same issue with depth
first so i don't really object to that
right
i mean
well okay
here's another
this is from nick but but here's another
possibility
this could be
okay
i mean one possibility would be to name
this depth first traversal to make it
clear that's the traversal
not the evaluation is that useful is
that not useful is that just super
confusing right so i'm well maybe it's
clarifying because it it
explains why a pre-order and post order
are both the same traversal it's just a
matter of when you apply the function
before or after the traversal
okay well fine enough i mean traversal
order depth first traversal
in outer inner
and that's like outer and inner is
telling you how to hook onto that
traversal to tell you when do you apply
the function while you're doing the
traversal
right
and if we say leaves first traversal
is that right or is that if we outer
inner we could say leaves first
traversal you've traversed it
but now
yeah you will inevitably
either if you're doing outer inner or
inner outer you are inevitably going to
have to traverse all the way down to all
of the leaves
okay so i think this is a reasonable way
to do it that then it's consistent with
our breadth first scan breadth first you
know that first scan
depth top bottom left right
is that correct what nick has said
though
are those in fact the possibilities
some of them
okay
but it's going to matter
okay
well i think we've got a reasonable plan
here okay so so the only thing that's
bothering me
is that depth first traversal
top down left right
is different from depth first traversal
left right top down correct
yes
it's not terrible
but it doesn't matter
in if you put the depth first traversal
in principle
the only ordering that matters is top
down left right versus left right top
down oh oh wait i misunderstood your
question um
you're asking if it matters whether you
specify left right
before outer inner yes
not with not if we're splitting it up
like this
okay oh because we've got the depth
first thing yeah exactly if you if you
don't have that first row of the three
categories then you're basically
simulating that with whether or not you
have outer
before left
or left before outer i get it i get it
okay this is looking good uh ethan is
commenting tree map indexed what's its
what's the story with that
do we have that functionality because we
need it
get it
i think we should
all right and that thing i was trying to
do with true replace on subparts you're
adding that right
tree replace part
yeah tree replace part with it with none
with
a
an arbitrary subtree
right yeah
so we need to go i'm sorry i have to go
i'm supposed to do another live stream
um
and i need something to eat first
so okay this has been very productive
and um
uh
yeah complicated subject but i think we
managed to get to a good result here
thanks to you guys thanks to folks on
the live stream bunch of good
suggestions very helpful
and uh let's iterate further and you'll
hear more about multi-way computation
and
the things around that soon